d'abord travailler plus pour gagner plus
on la connaît cette phrase là et j'en
parlais justement avec des gens dans le
public vous savez quand on a travaillé
par exemple dans le bâtiment toute sa
vie quand on à poser du carrelage et
qu'on a passé une partie de sa vie à
genoux quand on est quand on a des
métiers pénibles quand on travaille l
usine compass 6-7 heures debout on a
deux pause de 20 minutes
qu'on fait 10 13 km par jour il ya plein
de métiers comme ça qu'on soit soignants
conçoit gardiens de prison qu'on soit
ouvrier je peux vous dire que vous
pouvez leur dire travailler plus on est
mort et dans sa tête et dans son corps
ensuite ensuite dans les cinq ans qui
viennent de se passer je vais prendre
que ces 500 ces cinq ans là on a vu que
les plus riches avaient vu leur
patrimoine doubler les plus riches
aujourd'hui sont plus riches mais ils
ont vu leur patrimoine doubler les 500
plus grandes fortunes de france qui paye
l isf les 10% les plus riches détiennent
la moitié de du patrimoine de 2,2 des
français alors je pose la question à
ceux qui nous regardent à voula est-ce
que vous en cinq ans vous avez vu votre
patrimoine doublé est-ce que vous avez
vu votre salaire doublé est ce que les
retraités ils ont vu leur salaire doublé
c'est parce que j'entends non moi
j'entends plutôt que non seulement on
gagne pas plus même pouvoir d'achat et
la bc parce que non seulement les
salaires et non pas augmenter les
retraites l on peut augmenter voire même
elles ont baissé pour ceux qui ont vu là
la csg augmenté
il ya même ceux qui ont vu leur cotisent
agirc-arrco ils se reconnaîtront
puisqu'il ya eu un taux d'appel plus
élevés ils ont perdu même de la retraite
et puis ils ont vu leur facture
augmenter alors çà çà çà y est allé et
se serait pas vu de tout mettre sur le
dos de la guerre d'ailleurs parce que ça
a commencé à enfler avant la guerre gaz
électricité et essence les mutuelles les
loyers les assurances vous pouvez y
aller 1 et donc le pouvoir d'achat il a
largement baissé alors voilà comment on
peut expliquer que pendant ces cinq ans
y compris avec une pandémie comment se
fait-il qu'une infime minorité de notre
pays vivre aujourd'hui ils sabrent même
le champagne en ce moment parce qu cac
40 c'est la teuf et de l'autre côté la
grande majorité de la population c'est
la ceinture et moi j'entends ça quand je
m'en vais voir les salariés dans les
entreprises dans le public comme dans le
privé d'ailleurs ils sont colère il ya
un ouvrier de chez moi il a dit il y en
a marre c'est fini il faut que les
cigares échange de bouche comme il m'a
dit il faut que les riches y paye et qui
payent leurs impôts comme tout le monde
parce que la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y a des grandes entreprises des
multinationales qui payent leurs impôts
sur
les bénéfices sur les dividendes ils
font tout ce qu'il faut pour pas le
payer et ils payent entre 4 à 8 %
d'impôts alors qu'une pme llp 15% alors
que normalement ces multinationales
devrait payer 30% fin maintenant ça a
été ramené à 27 parmi les cadeaux et qui
ont été faits aux multinationales ce
n'est pas juste ce n'est pas juste faire
enfin et ils ont eu la suppression de l'
isf est donc ce que je demande moi c'est
que quand on est dans une période aussi
difficile que celle que nous ayons je
demande tout simplement qui est de la
solidarité et du partage des richesses
enfin ces richesses dont je parle celles
produites par notre travail celle
produite par ce qu'ils sont et dans les
usines mais pas que et puis le travail
de ceux qui sont dans des services
publics mais qui sont quand même
vachement utile 1 les enseignants et
soignants les a vus ceux qui travaillent
dans les administrations ceux qui sont
dans les communes dans les villages qui
sont allés porter les plats ou aux
anciens pendant les confinements enfin
quand même heureusement qu'ils étaient
là de tout cela eh bien moi ce que je
demande c'est que toutes ces richesses
que nous produisons on puisse les mettre
au service de tous au service du pays
des salaires au service des retraites
pour pouvoir les augmenter au service de
la dignité et même au service du travail
je veux une france de la bonne paye une
france des salaires et donc je suis pour
le rétablissement de l'isf l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune je suis pour
non seulement le rétablir mais le triplé
parce que il ya du gras quand même y'a
de quoi faire on peut ça leur fera pas
de mal franchement ils vivront pas moins
bien je suis pour m place le prélèvement
à la source des bénéfices des
multinationales
ça c'est la mesure fiscale
radicale pour lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale c'est un véritable fléau la
fraude fiscale l'optimisation fiscale
optimisation surtout c'est surtout ça la
différence entre la fraude fiscale et
l'optimisation fiscale c'est l'épaisseur
d'un mur de prison parce qu'il y en a
une qui est interdite et l'autre qui
autorisait exactement ça fait autant de
mal au pays c'est sûr mais il manque au
budget de l'état tous les ans 80 à 100
milliards d'euros à cause de la fraude
et de l'optimisation fiscale terminée
c'est honteux c'est dégueulasse c'est un
coup de poignard dans le dos du pacte
républicain
c'est de l'argent qui manque pour
construire des écoles des hôpitaux pour
augmenter les salaires pour
réindustrialiser la france pour relever
le défi climatique pour permettre aux
retraités d'avoir une bonne retraite
même pour pouvoir leur permettre de
partir plus tôt quand ils sont cassés
par le boulot voilà et donc je souhaite
moi qu'on mette nos richesses au service
du travail au service de la dignité
humaine au service de nos services
publics nos hôpitaux nos écoles la
sécurité j'en ai beaucoup parlé dans la
campagne parce que c'est important voilà
qu'on qu'on y met les moyens c'est notre
argent quand même alors oui je veux
m'attaquer à la fraude fiscale à
l'optimisation fiscale je veux même le
mettre dans la campagne dès que je peux
dès que je parle dans les médias je le
dis la fraude fiscale c'est un fléau il
faut ici attaqué fermement et c'est
comme ça que je propose le prélèvement à
la source des bénéfices des
multinationales fin quand même on nous
le fait à nous nous nous prélève à la
source nos impôts pourquoi on ne le fait
pas pour ces multinationales pourquoi ne
prélèverait ton pas leurs bénéfices
avant que ceux-ci part dans les paradis
fiscaux au luxembourg en irlande
au au bahamas aux îles caïmans face ça
va quoi fabien roussel - autre chose je
trouve ça mais est ce que vous n'avez
pas peur qu'ils aient une délocalisation
après de toutes les entreprises parce
que vous parlez de parler d'
optimisation savez ce qui va se passer
et ils vont pouvoir optimiser donc ils
vont pour yvon partir ailleurs sur la
nouvelle je vais vous dire les
délocalisations de ces multinationales
elles existent déjà la wii et ils ont
déjà mis leurs sièges sociaux dont les
paradis fiscaux
c'est déjà le cas vous avez entendu
parler de ce scandale des cabinets
conseils que gouvernement macron à
utiliser pour remplacer l'administration
deux milliards et demi d'euros de
factures pour des cabinets privés 1 cd
pas des cabinets de toilette ça serait
des cabinets en or mais c'est des
cabinets conseils avec des monsieur bien
habillés qui vous donne des conseils
pour vous dire comment on peut aller
gratter des sous sur les apl comment on
peut aller gratter des sous sur les
hôpitaux sur les écoles deux milliards
et demi d'euros ce gouvernement il aura
donné à ces cabinets conseils dont le
cabinet mckinsey vous en avez entendu
parler on en a parlé tous notre collègue
sénatrice eliane assassi sénatrice
communiste avec le groupe communiste au
sénat qui avait mené cette commission
d'enquêté qui a révélé ce scandale comme
quoi d'avoir des parlementaires
communistes ça sert c'est le vote utile
le dga sert aussi passer d'un rapport du
sénat et c'est tous les sénateurs disent
qu'ils 600 mines tout à fait mais là
dessus personne ne peut approuver ce qui
a été fait
le cabinet mckinsey le cabinet mckinsey
qui sont les grands amis du candidat
macron puisque macron les avait
utilisées pour préparer sa campagne donc
il aura bien servi la soupe derrière
2002 milliard et demi en tout dont le
cabinet mckinsey vous savez où est son
siège au cabinet mckinsey au delà were
aux états unis je prononce mal je suis
du nord de la whey non monsieur le maire
ça marche
ça comme tupperware avec le dollar
exactement
les deux là où air et bien le de la
loire est un état des états unis coûté
bien celle là c'est énorme le delaware
est un état des états unis où il y a
neuf cent mille habitants mais il y à un
million cent mille entreprises
domiciliées vous y croyez à ça ça existe
là-bas ya plus d'entreprises que
d'habitants mais on a la même chose au
luxembourg c'est des boîtes aux lettres
bien sûr ces des voleurs c'est des
boîtes aux lettres en fait ils créent
des entreprises offshore dont lesquels
l'argent notamment quand même c'est
l'argent de notre travail les bénéfices
de ces mots de ce cabinet conseil et des
boîtes vassan des sociétés danser sauter
et ses sociétés offshore qui sont créés
dans des états ou des pays et c'est
quand il y en a en europe le luxembourg
est bien connu ils payent pas d'impôts
où ils payent un impôt marginal par
rapport à celui qui le paierait en
france mais c'est du vol c'est du racket
mon choix quand est ce qu'on va s'y
attaquer fermement franchement moi pour
moi ce sont vraiment des délinquants en
col blanc ça rapporterait plus que de
s'attaquer à cela un tout haut qu'au
petit cela ils vont rapporter du pognon
peux vous dire que vous embauchez 15000
contrôleurs fiscaux comme moi je veux le
faire pas pour aller chatouiller les
artisans et les pme mais pour aller
chercher les gros
d'ailleurs je dis il faut que les gros
pays gros et que les petits paye petit
voilà je paye pas de la taille je parle
des multinationales un nom parle pas du
physique mais au moins si on s'attaque
alors on a dit pas le physique n'est pas
la pensée n'est pas là pour ça mais que
les grosses boîtes
payent leurs justes impôts et qu'on
arrête avec les petits mais que ces
grosses boîtes justement on a et leur
prélever l'impôt qu'ils doivent payer et
je dis même plus
mais qu'il y ait de la solidarité même
de la solidarité nationale du
patriotisme
parlons-en entre ceux qui ne payent plus
liesse fille qui devrait le payer et ces
multinationales qui devrait contribuer
160 milliards d'euros de bénéfices pour
ces grosses boîtes du cac 40 et elle
arrive à délocaliser leur pognon dans
les paradis fiscaux moi j'en connais une
ne s'est pas une boîte du cac 40 mais
c'est le fonds apollo un fonds américain
qui investit dans plein de boîtes de la
métallurgie de la sidérurgie
de connaître mais ce fonds apollo au
fait des opérations boursières fait des
plus values boursières et cet argent
c'est plus value qu'ils font j'ai une
opération aux têtes un milliard d'euros
de plus value c'est parti dans leurs
sociétés off shore au luxembourg et du
luxembourg on a la trace de st d'environ
2 500 millions d'euros aux îles caïmans
voilà et ça c'est de l'argent qui a été
prélevé sur les ouvriers du groupe
verallia qui font des bouteilles en
verre voilà on leur a fermé un four on
leur a demandé de travailler beaucoup et
ce groupe apollo anciennement ils ont
racheté saint gobain et ils se sont fait
du beurre sur nous un bien c'est
scandaleux fabian est scandaleux on ne
peut plus le permettre d'ailleurs je
reviens sur l' isf je suis pourvu
qu'elles aient valérie pécresse
madame pécresse est ce que vous êtes
pour établir lisf
voire le triplé mais au moins le
rétablir et qu'il y ait une mesure de
solidarité l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune et je rappelle que quand il
existe l isf en
2013 il devait y en avoir 300 hommes
15300 12000 de redevables à liez s
allier sef et en 2017 il y en avait
trois cent soixante mille plus
ça toujours été un peu croissant ya
quasiment pas de départ à cause de l'
isf mais parce que en france ils sont du
gras gagne 10 ou n'a pas de problème
donc ils préfèrent payer isf et ben moi
je suis certain qu ici en france ya des
riches qui sont prêts à payer les sf qui
sont prêts à le faire et apporter leur
contribution parce qu'en période de
guerre en période de pandémie on doit
tous tous faire un effort madame
pécresse
d'accord pour établir les sf alors
répondez lui s'il va repartir
alors moi moi je suis pas pour augmenter
les impôts voilà genre les dirigeants
nommés attendait à connaître tu monsieur
marcel je vous ai écouté vous avez été
janvier au camp et vous avez très bien
défendu cette france qui travaille et
moi je veux la défendre aussi parce que
travailler plus pour gagner plus c'était
effectivement le slogan de nicolas
sarkozy mais dans mon programme
aujourd'hui c'est je veux le travail qui
paye et le coeur de mon projet justement
c'est d'augmenter les salaires tous les
salaires dès le mois de juin tous les
salaires de tous ceux qui travaillent 2
3% en enlevant un tiers des cotisations
retraite et en prenant cet argent et
c'est l'état qui le financera et je veux
et ça veut dire que pour tous les
français qui travaillent aujourd'hui qui
vous l'avez dit ont été en première
ligne ils auront sur leur feuille de
paye une augmentation dès le mois de
juin parce que moi aussi monsieur
lorsque attendait tant d'états détendent
et non là vraiment monsieur au sel vous
êtes très sympathique mais je vous ai
écouté pendant
un petit menu petites minutes 10 minutes
moi je veux être la candidate de la
feuille de paye alors effectivement
effectivement quand on gagne 400 euros
net aujourd'hui avec moi on aura 500
euros de salaire de plus dans sur un an
et ça commence en juin et puis je ferai
une grande conférence sociales et
salariales avec les syndicats et avec
les entreprises et je veux qu'on ait une
vraie stratégie pour augmenter les
salaires parce que vous l'avez dit le
coût de la vie explose et aujourd'hui le
pouvoir d'achat ne suit pas et donc on a
besoin aujourd'hui que les français
vivent dignement de leur salaire et
dignement de leur retraite parce que les
retraités ont été aussi les grands
oubliés du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
mais pourquoi les retraités ont été les
grands oubliés parce qu emmanuel macron
n'a pas eu le courage de faire la
réforme des retraites on va en parler et
quand on fait pas de réforme eh bien on
n'a pas d'argent et quand on n'a pas
d'argent eh ben on peut pas indexer les
retraites sur l'inflation donc avec moi
les retraites elles sont indexées sur
l'inflation est avec moi on aura une
vraie réforme des retraites est une
vraie garantie pour que les retraités ne
perd pas en pouvoir d'achat mais sur les
salaires il n'ya pas seulement
l'augmentation des salaires il ya aussi
la possibilité de payer mieux les
fonctionnaires vous avez parlé des
fonctionnaires les fonctionnaires pour
pouvoir les payer mieux il faut de
l'argent là encore donc moi je ferai la
réforme de l'état et j'aurai moins de
fonctionnaires mieux payés et puis je
veux qu'on puisse effectivement
travailler plus pour gagner plus si on
en a envie et si on l'aimé tout comme
l'a dit fabien roussel parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya des métiers forte
pénibilité c'est vrai qu'un maçon ou et
d'infirmiers en rue et ils savent très
bien pour travailler plus mais ils
peuvent pas ils sont pas faciles d'abord
ça dépend des métiers et moi c'est tous
les salaires qu'on augmente vous l'avez
bien compris tous les travers the lady
est mon objectif sur le quinquennat
c'est 10 % d'augmentation des salaires
nets de l'inflation la plus doux les
salaires et je veux que mes réformes
parce qu il va falloir faire des
réformes aujourd'hui on est champion du
monde du poids des impôts champion du
monde des impôts et vous savez bien que
trop d'impôt celi jamais celle pour la
tuer ils ont été aussi bas pour le riz
l'anchois ça que emmanuel macron et
était le président des jeux bien voulu
laisser dire mais moi je serai là
candidate qui augmentera les salaires de
tous sur les français j'ai dit non j'ai
dit je remonte pas les impôts d'accord
je ne monte pas les impôts jeu les
baisses les bébés pour moi parce que les
pillards mais cette nouvelle commande en
ligne
a aujourd'hui demain un impôt sur la
fortune immobilière donc qui existent
encore celui là je le maintiens
maintenant je ne sais pas je non je ne
le touche je ne je ne veux le maintient
en revanche ce que je fais c'est que je
fais un certain nombre de réformes pour
défense et mieux l'argent et pour
pouvoir baisser les cotisations
retraites sur les salaires de façon à
augmenter les salaires de tous les
français voilà
qu'on est j'ai une deux ou trois autres
mesures de baisse fiscale aujourd'hui
les parallèles comme sont bons c'est
important d'en parler non c'est
important parce que je me suis rendu
compte aussi qu'on avait on avait une
situation très injuste c'est celle des
mamans solos des mères séparées ce qu'on
appelle les familles monoparentales
alors ça c'est c'est c'est le
politiquement correct on dit les
familles monoparentales puis on fait
souvent des mères seules et quand elles
ont des pensions alimentaires pour leurs
enfants vous savez que les mères seules
quand on est séparés ces 20% de coût de
la vie en plus parce qu'on a deux
appartements parce qu'on doit vivre on
doit payer deux fois et bien ces mamans
seules
quand elles ont des pensions
alimentaires pour leurs enfants elles
sont fiscalisées moi je les
défiscalisent ray et que ce soit pour
les ouvriers dans les usines que ce soit
pour les fonctionnaires que ce soit pour
les travailleurs de première ligne je
veux vraiment une hausse du pouvoir
d'achat et j'ajoute une autre chose je
souhaite qu'on a une priorité dans le
logement social aux travailleurs de
première ligne parce qu'aujourd'hui avec
la crise qu vide il ya finalement une
nouvelle fracture qui c'est une fête en
france entre les français qui ont la
chance de pouvoir télétravailler et
c'est une chose vraie chance parce
qu'ils peuvent de temps en temps ne pas
prendre les transports ils peuvent
rester chez eux et ils ont cette chance
là et puis il ya les français qui ne
peuvent pas télétravail et parce que ils
sont dans des emplois postés ils sont
effectivement dans des usines ils sont
caissières dans des supermarchés ils
sont agents d'entretien et eux ils ont
besoin d'habiter près de là il travaille
donc je veux qu'ils aient une priorité
dans le logement social pour ces
travailleurs de première ligne et puis
moi je rêve d'une france de
propriétaires monsieur à 1h01 france de
propriétaires ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire aider tous les jeunes ménages des
jeunes groupes aujourd'hui à pouvoir
devenir propriétaire et pour ça il ya un
outil qui s'appelle le prêt à taux zéro
qui permet à des jeunes qui n'ont pas
d'apport initiale de pouvoir devenir
propriétaire aujourd'hui le prêt à taux
zéro déjà fricker durban les grandes
métropoles c'est que dans les grandes
métropoles et bien moi j'ai dresser les
états unis avoir un prêt à taux zéro
pour qu'ils puissent rembourser son prêt
étudiant quand il est devenu président
de la république votre système c'est le
système américain c'est terrible c'est
pas du tout le système américain ça
marche très bien et prêt à taux zéro si
ça permet de se faire pour le prix d'un
c'est inviter les jeunes à s'endetter
pour pouvoir payer leurs études je peux
vous dire qu'avec un système comme ça si
ensuite après les jeunes ils n'ont pas
de boulot et remboursent jamais leurs
prêts c'est comme ça qu'on on a des
crises et que la résine y ont peur de
cette visée libre attendait non pardon
je suis je peux répondre parce que c'est
pas du tout mon projet au contraire moi
je veux mettre en place une banque pour
aider les jeunes à financer leurs études
pour lutter contre l'autocensure des
jeunes et 1 me en bourse et on ne
rembourse que quand on atteint un
certain niveau de salaire ça veut dire
qu'on ne remboursait pas si on gagne pas
suffisamment bien sa vie donc ça veut
dire qu'on peut faire des études avec
l'esprit serein
nous serons à ce que je vous dis encore
iron bonjour j'aimerais ça monsieur
roussel le problème des études en france
et vous le savez bien c'est que on croit
que l'université gratuite mais il ya
quand même des études qui sont restés et
vivre dans une ville universitaire ça
coûte très cher et quand on est dans les
ardennes à les livres à un beurre par
les plus chers quand on est en dordogne
à livre ouvert par l'état est c'est vrai
que la wii on nous reste trois minutes
un oui bon je vous ai parlé qu'une fois
bon alors là
non mais vous n'avez parlé qu'une fois
15 minutes non c'est pas vrai
oui bravo 15 minutes mais c'était très
sympa ça t4 mais j'ai pas vu passer ses
normes et ses minauderies alors le vidéo
moi je nous non plus on l'a pas vu pas
d'accord alors j'allais non jeu mais je
dois aussi répondre sans la provençale
des grands corps est ce que j'adore on
n'a pas les liait savoir quand même
d'abord sur les retraites je vais pas le
dire je sais que on va en parler avec un
dernier à quatre mains va revenir dessus
et il pourra comme ça lui apporter la
contradiction parce que je sais pas
comment madame pécresse financera la
hausse des retraites en allant taper
dans la caisse des retraites mais ça à
la vente avec adrien la question des
salaires d'abord 3 % 10 % sur cinq ans
mais c'est 10% tout de suite minimum et
encore moi je propose 20 ans mais si on
fait ça mais vous rendez compte 3%
également financer mais vous vous rendez
compte mais comment mais allez demander
à ce talentueux groupe peugeot allait
demander aux grandes entreprises de
l'industrie justement vous savez qu'il
ya des salariés il ya des ouvriers ils
font grève pendant une semaine pour
gagner 10 euros et parce que les nao
l'aller les négociations annuelles
obligatoires elles sont bloquées légales
et les taux de l'ieee lâche rien les
petites boîtes encore elles sont prêtes
à faire des efforts pour trouver des
bassins sera donnant-donnant les bébés à
l'impôt il va l'aimer la peau des
connexions rien ils veulent les impôts
de production
mais sur les indemnités kilométriques
alors que l'essence n'a jamais et n'a
jamais été aussi cher ces grandes boîtes
je pense à alstom que j'ai rencontrés
ils ont dû se mettre en grève pour
gagner 17 euros par an de hausse
d'indemnités kilométriques 17 euros par
an d'indemnités kilométriques de plus
quand on voit le prix de l'essence c'est
du foutage de gueule enfin entre nous
c'est pas 3% de hausse de salaire qu'il
faut madame pécresse vous rendez compte
que ça représente c'est peanuts par
rapport au coût de la vie aujourd'hui
loris de la relation monsieur lancé en
plus de l'inflation l'inflation est déjà
4% cette année ce sens puisque vous
allez bien devoir dire à toutes ces
entreprises allaient bien devoir
importer le smic et l'augmenter tout de
suite au moins 10% tout dessus sinon ça
ne pourra jamais répondre aux besoins
des gens comment voulez vous essayer
d'envoyer donner envie aux gens d'aller
travailler pour des salaires de misère
qui rapporte pas comment vous allez
financer vos réformes comment vous allez
financer les besoins du pays avec un
budget riquiqui parce que vous allez
baisser les impôts comment vous allez
prendre en charge la question du
handicap dont on parle messieurs ou dans
celle enfin c'est quand même fort de
café est temps de casser la différence
entre entre la droite et le parti
communiste que vous représentez c'est
que nous on sait que la générosité un
coup donc moi toutes mes émotions elles
sont financées toutes mes visions à se
financer votre projet
milliards comment vous les trouvez vous
croyez que les multinationales elles
vont accepter de peuvent les payer vos
impôts moi je vais mettre en place pour
le ministère de la lutte
risque à l'entraînement sf1 vous rêvez
combien ils étaient a payé les sf dans
le dernier rapport ça c'est le rapport
que j'ai eu à l'assemblée nationale je
les révéler il est sur mon site famille
roussel de 250 milliards contre 3
milliards comme ça vous savez ce que
c'est là dessus là c'est le rapport qui
indique que en 2018 la dernière année où
il ya eu les sf dont il ya des chiffres
je vais vous laisser monsieur hanouna
alors les croissants 58 mille foyers ont
payé l'isf en 2010 7 358 mille soyez et
il avait un patrimoine taxable
2028 milliards d'euros mille 28
milliards d'euros pour trois cent
cinquante huit mille foyers vous n'allez
pas me dire qu'à pas un petit peu de
gras prendre pour répondre aux besoins
du pays mais c'est bien pour ça que sur
1000 28 milliards d'euros on en
prendrait 10 ce qui leur reste un petit
peu quand même de quoi voir
et donc c'est ça que je dis et puis si
on a un parmi ceux là ces trois cent
cinquante huit mille foyers qui dit
comment ça je vais devoir payer l'isf
mais je pars m'exiler en belgique comme
certains font d'ailleurs ça connaît le
savez si on vous le savez on se remet
jamais loupé sa
tanière vous quitteriez la france si
vous deviez payer c'est alors c'est
totalement torture alors je vous dis la
vérité je ne veux pas est déjà lié cf et
comme chez les filles les filles doivent
y voilà les filles et moi je paye déjà
oui bah alors dont sept enfants restés
en france
il ya un truc à une conscience aussi
comme a dit fabien roussel et je le dis
là la france normalement on a on a même
moi je vois là je gagne très bien ma vie
je les ai toujours dit je suis très bien
ma vie mais je dois quelque chose à la
france et l' or là c'est normal
sinon c'est nouveau
piqué le mandat qui vient avec un budget
rabougri un budget de la france petit
les français en ont marre qu'on leur
dise va falloir faire des efforts va
falloir travailler plus longtemps vous
allez payer plus cher c'est comme ça
c'est la guerre on peut pas faire
autrement basta moi je veux des réformes
heureuse je veux du positif je veux
qu'on vive et je veux convives heureux
je suis exigeant je veux convives
heureux est heureux de son travail et
heureux en retraite aussi et pas en
retraite cassé par le travail en
retraite en bonne santé pour pouvoir en
profiter pour pouvoir vivre
merci ça qu'on veut c'est ça
merci mais on aimerait tous mais on
aimerait tous que ce soit possible mais
ce sera pas seulement avec votre réforme
de lier celle que vous y avez monsieur
on en tourne vers les france ô le
fronton de mai pour le fai veulent pour
les aujourd'hui engagement bah moi mes
engagements je les tiens et moi j'ai
gouverner et moi j'ai dirigé et dans ma
région quand j'ai pris un engagement je
les tenais le seul bris d'engagement
warrick usus et des jours sans pour 6%
de hausse des salaires